bonjour et merci d'être avec nous alors
après l'allemagne c'est la belgique
inquiets le plus touchés par ces
intempéries la montée du niveau des
cours d eau a causé la mort d'au moins
27 personnes vous êtes à liège là bas
quelle est l'ampleur des dégâts on parle
de quartier complètement dévastée oui
tout à fait évidemment on a beaucoup
d'amis qui habitent dans ces quartiers
qui ont été sous deux mètres d'eau donc
le rez-de-chaussée était complètement
submergées
c'est assez cataclysmique
ça l'a été dit par différentes personnes
là en antenne dans le reportage
il y a les dégâts sont tellement diffus
et répartis sur toute la région qu'en
réalité les l'aide officielle a vraiment
énormément difficultés à pouvoir
parvenir aux différents endroits
simultanément et donc dieu merci il ya
une entraide qui qui se faire entre
citoyens et qui permet en fait de de
parer au plus pressé notamment en ce qui
concerne la la le nettoyage et le
déblaiement en tout cas dans un premier
temps puis oui beaucoup de solidarité on
l'a vu dans le reportage
expliquez-nous pourquoi le lien entre
cet événement météo extrêmement et le
changement climatique ne semble plus
faire aucun doute parce que en réalité
quelles que soient les endroits où on a
fait les mesures de débit
c'est à dire la quantité d'eau en mètres
cubes seconde qui passe à un endroit
tous ses records ont été explosées
mais quand je dis explosé il ya des
endroits où c'est dix fois quinze fois
le record enregistré au cours du dernier
cycle donc on est dans une danse et
situation jamais vue auparavant
ça c'est un premier élément est le
deuxième élément extrêmement perturbant
c'est qu'en réalité nous sommes en été
d'habitude ce genre de deux
d'inondations peut subvenir
malheureusement autres nous heureusement
pas non de tel
niveau d'intensité mais c'est l'habitude
fargues automne ou en hiver où on a une
conjugaison depuis intense sur le long
terme également de fonte des neiges qui
sont dans les ardennes un peu en
altitude et donc on a tout cela qui va
s'ajouter qu'il va faire en sorte que
l'on à des inondations
évidemment ici nous sommes embêtés et on
ajuste jamais vu ça donc tout exploser
et la saison n'est pas la bonne
donc on est on est vraiment dans un cas
de figure réellement exceptionnel et je
pense que c'est ça qui a fait en sorte
également que l'on ne prennent pas la
mesure du risque que la population de
laval unis est en train de courir
lorsque des les systèmes de prix que
sont 10 et qu'il fallait mettre tout le
monde à l'abri climatique le changement
climatique est présenté comme une menace
pour nos enfants pour nos petits enfants
finalement pour la génération future
est ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours ne nous rappelle quitte
pas que le changement climatique est un
ange est bien présent bien sûr en fait
ce n'est pas à venir
c'est maintenant c'est maintenant et ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on se
retrouve face à des situations
exceptionnelles jamais vu auparavant
rappelez-vous en 2003 nous avions eu
cette vague de chaleur qui a quand même
fait en europe 70 mille morts quelque
chose d'hallucinant c'était la pire
catastrophe depuis depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale dont 15000 morts en
france notamment jones --la ce sont des
choses qui n'étaient jamais qui ne
s'était jamais réalisé auparavant
et ici à nouveau on se retrouve dans une
situation exceptionnelle puisqu'on est
on est à nouveau je me répète mais on
n'est pas dans la bonne saison on est
dans quelque chose qui n'a jamais été
observé
avant mais qui est quelque chose qui est
prévu par les différents scénarios des
climatologues dont je fais partie et ça
fait 30 ans qu'avec le gic donc le
groupe intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat nous dit
crittenton de crier haut et fort que
cela va arriver et en fait maintenant on
y est
mais c'est quelque chose totalement
prévisibles malheureusement alors
justement on sait que la communauté
scientifique a alerté anticiper ce genre
de catastrophe naturelle manifestement
vous n'êtes pas assez entendue par écrit
concrètement mais entendu pas passer en
fait on a évidemment maintenant l'union
européenne qui a décidé de de faire un
effort extrêmement important de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 puisqu'il est question de faire
moins 55 % d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 par rapport à 1990
très bien dont tect mais moi je remarque
en belgique pour l'instant par rapport à
et bien en fait on est toujours à -20%
donc il va falloir faire des efforts
considérables et je ne suis pas
convaincu que cela va se produire dans
le sens où on sait que nous n'avons pas
le choix parce qu'on fait les dégâts
matériels de ces catastrophes ont retiré
son gigantesque entre les années 80 et
les années 2010 l'impact économique de
ces catastrophes naturelles liées aux
changements climatiques en europe a été
multiplié par deux
vous imaginez ça est en fait chaque fois
qu'on a une catastrophe naturelle
on a bien sûr des personnes qui sont
couvertes par les assurances mais des
personnes qui ne le sont pas et donc
l'impact de ces catastrophes naturelles
liées au changement climatique ne va
faire qu'une chose c'est accentuer les
disparités entre ceux qui ont les moyens
de pouvoir se protéger et ceux qui ne
les ont pas alors en belgique on a la
chance d'avoir
60 % de ces dégâts matériels qui sont
couverts par les assurances mais si on
regarde en europe de l'est ou en
méditerranée notamment en italie ou au
portugal ou en grèce
pas même dix pour cent des dégâts liés
au changement climatique sont couverts
par les assurances et donc ça veut dire
que la majeure partie de ces deux
sénégal matériel et économique repose en
fait sur les individus ou sur les
collectivités lequel nationale et donc
ça a un coût phénoménal pour en fait le
lien social
on en est là et ce n'est pas seulement
une vision de l'esprit qu'on peut avoir
dans des pays du sud
extrêmement pauvres etc non nous sommes
en europe et en europe
ceci va contribuer en fait accentuée les
disparités sociales et c'est là
également un des drames osait remercie
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes climatologues
docteur en sciences géographiques à
l'université de liège mercier